goddamn t-pain
oh
might oh i saw this i saw the video i
just i'm gonna get into the story right
now
but t-pain bro i mean we all know t-pain
okay this story is basically how t-pain
says he blew 40 million dollars in 10
years a 40 million dollar fortune
all his money gone
and the worst of it he's laughing about
it
he's having the time of his life
laughing about it the worst is he's
gotta he's not telling it on oprah
he's not telling freaking pvd
he's sitting down with this jackass
stevo
the last person you want to be like
get a load of this
look how much my life is in shambles
stevo knows a thing or two about life in
shambles anyway t-pain's a legend
musically financially
not a legend at all
buy you a drink what else uh i'm sprung
yes uh did you get
he's got some classics out there smack
that
reach back and make me smack that that's
him at eminem oh that's a con jesus
you're all over the place
anyway buy you a drink buy your drink
i'm sprung bart
look he's sold over 16 million 16
million records 50 million uh digital
tracks worldwide he's busted on the
scene since what early 2000s he's the
tallahassee hero i went to florida state
so i know he's from tallahassee but
here's another sad freaking case about
rappers just not understanding how money
works yeah they want to make it freaking
rain
and they forget to bring an umbrella
yeah it's sad so anyway he gets on a
recent podcast with jackass over here
stevo no offense devo but not exactly
the brightest uh you know tool in the
shed not exactly the brightest crayon
out there the the sharpest tool on the
show most of jackass
jackass and basically t-pain
sort of chuckling i don't know if you
want to pull up a picture of him there
we go he basically says i gotta he
revealed his lack of a financial mindset
and uh that led to him blowing 40
million freaking dollars in the space of
12 years and he eventually ended up
filing for bankruptcy um pre-covet 2019.
yeah all right and here's his quote and
like i hear this and i i want to like
run all up in the studio and shake him
by the his neck by like whatever this
area is his collar
he said this nobody ever sat me down
explained that all this good stuff can
eventually go away
all these singers these musicians these
athletes that i knew they kept saying
that once the money started rolling in
it's gonna stay that way forever what
the
bleep worst advice who the told you
that
who said hey man everything you're doing
this ain't gonna stop
the good times will last forever yeah
there's never any issues maybe it's
dimesh saw but he forgot to tell him to
eight steps i don't know close bro i
don't know who the hell it was
but whoever was in this guy's ear you
know pat always talks about who's in
your ear who's in your ear who's the
last person to talk to who's in your ear
whoever's in this guy's ear
maybe it was the bartender yeah he had
bad breath yeah who knows what's going
on he basically t-pain claims
he never bothered to check his bank
balances
okay he assumed the royalty checks would
keep rolling in all right
he assumed that the numbers would only
go up never down why would he and on top
of that he left all the people around
him the people he trusted spend whatever
they wanted without checking the bottom
line t-pain what the actual is
going on here tell them sauce this
pisses me off
when's the last time t-pain had a hit
dude when was the last dude you get one
life
you get this one shot to make your money
and you freaking blow it
jesus and then get this story
among his many extravagances great word
extravagances
he bought a brand new bugatti for 2.1
million dollars only to sell it a short
time later for 800 grand
to which stevo
financial advisor to the stars stevo
says he asserts that's like spending 1.3
million dollars just to rent a car
thanks stevo
[Laughter]
look the bottom line is t-pain i love
your music but your decision-making
skills are lackluster at best when stevo
is correcting your mental know-how
you got a problem bro
when steve is basically saying hey that
maybe wasn't the best financial decision
you could have made you dumb up
t-pain
i'm fired up right now dude you should
be like this is my entire brand save
that money
invest in things you care about don't
just be
blowing checks like tomorrow's not going
to be is guaranteed
this is
it pisses me off
t-pain
bring him on the show i gotta talk to
this guy can i see this guy's face right
now what the are you laughing at t-pain
come on this ain't funny
i'm more pissed than him come with me i
got money in the bank but not for long
what song is that one
uh that's um i'm gonna buy you a drink
i'm gonna buy you a drink i've never
mixed it anyway
i'm a little fired up i'm gonna have a
drink of water right now t-pain you done
screwed up i don't know the last time he
had a hit but it it ain't the bartender
it ain't sprung he ain't buying nobody
drinks okay
what are people saying in the comment
section anything decent about team payne
paul brown
win win no matter what not really
paul brown says t-pain owe me 2 500
no cap
is that true
paul brown no way come on does he pound
actually owe you 2 500 bucks because
you're not you're not getting it he's
filed bankruptcy
anyway what's the what's the what's the
lesson here
i don't care if you make
40 million dollars four million dollars
four hundred thousand dollars yeah we
just talked about the beginning of the
show the average
average american over their lifetime
will make two million dollars be better
than average you can make three five ten
million dollars in your lifetime
don't pull a t-pain
why do it just don't have a budget spend
less than you make track your expenses
know how much is coming in the freaking
door
homie said
nobody ever sat me down and explained
all this good stuff can go away are you
kidding me
nobody figured that one out by yourself
yeah that takes that takes someone
forever that takes someone saying hey
buddy by the way you know
everything you're doing
there's no there's no end in sight
you're the man
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke
[Music]